I'm kooky some may know me from Stock
Exchange because I I work in Berlin we
mostly do play a pro CD f's and quite
recently we work on a bigger pocket for
the Christ now purposes it's part of
more larger project basically I'm
responsible for providing interface for
lectures teaching assistants that create
lectures assessments and so on and it
needs to be user friendly because
although they are familiar with foreign
language they are not programmers so now
I won't going to present what I learned
during my years in glue engine company I
must say it will be quite detailed
because yeah I will sprint to basic
stuff so I imagine everyone being or
should be familiar with those tutorials
I am glad that Lu presented talk
understanding dynamic motion because
it's part of what I'm going to say if
you are familiar with other talks of
front-end team there is a scale so the
hardest talk was 300 they are around 100
this is 500 I think so it doesn't mean
it is so nice it means it's quite tough
learning curve ok so I will briefly
mention basics of performance doing like
what you should do not do about I will
sprint through this I will mention front
and side programming because it's almost
not documented it's quite useful and
hardly anyone uses this outside go from
then I will go to the main point of this
the key point of this talk which is
first prototype of complex interfaces it
is a narrow or magnin are
it's part of the big picture of things
you may want to do with user interface
but it allows you to others very very I
would say are you have use cases there
are bonuses as usual in those talks so
as a warm-up
basically I'm imagining everyone needs
to understand that this is what you see
is only an image rendered by the front
end inside it is a cell structure which
basically consists of cell expressions
the symbols you may think our symbols
are just strings like button here right
so it's order buttons its input it's as
well the case for this input and once
you send it to evaluation yes okay
nothing happens because there are no
rules associated but you can also see
it's the same okay yeah there are
special rules for typesetting for
various different expressions so button
looks like this but this is what you
have in notebook cream so basically you
need to understand the box structure
behind and what that what you see is
only the way people choose to display it
to render and what you also can notice
that those special boxes like button box
for example they contain not only
strings
so there are symbols inside there too
this time the food is a symbol which is
important because this is part of the
bigger topic about how front-end part is
this input so many things will be useful
knowing that there are not only strings
that needs to be rendered in some way
okay so this is like very brief
introduction also very briefly I need to
assume that you know what's wrong here
so basically you have manipulated and
you want to
okay it's a terribly slow why is low
because you don't optimize your layout
you need to know that French style is a
front-end option it's on front-end
option you can specify it as dynamic so
that because now wherever I see the
whole body of money for it is evaluated
again and again it's slow as expected
because this is what is this time slope
form for those performance go and plot
points options so now
yeah it's smooth I mean because this the
see in manipulate is directly connected
by a front-end to the frame style I
mentioned tutorial advanced dynamic
functionality everything is more
detailed there so I'm just mentioning it
so that we kind of complete but we've
picture of what we are going to do next
okay so I I didn't focus on onion one
higher each week III find really useful
so I decided I will mention front and
side programming tool so you need to
know that when you hit shift enter I
think goes to the kernel there is
parsing step stage on the front and side
on the kernel side and it's evaluation
typesetting and so on formatting not
only think is important now but you need
to be who dis communication how it goes
there are feelings you can learn about
them in this tutorial I mentioned tried
earlier - but front-end can't do stuff
itself and it is faster because it
doesn't need to communicate with the
colonel it's more limited because
Mathematica is so very start that it
wouldn't be possible to probably allow
everything to happen throttle will have
kind of for this so the first section is
links nowhere I won't launch it now
because we don't have time for this this
is basically a tour which is built-in
so this is a setup this it's built in in
Mathematica Java is a kind of you can
see how the communication goes between
in front and kernel you cannot use it to
debug complex programs but you can test
ideas whether something to implement it
really works front inside or there is
communication maybe some other puppets
interfere like syntax
well auto completion or something like
this you I don't want to so it's fun to
know what's going on to report bugs over
now yeah okay so basic example front
side programming is maybe not obvious
but known to everyone this dynamic also
those variables are front and governed
let's say they're owned by front-end so
we can see we have two hundred sliders
here and it quite it is quite smooth
because there is no calculation needed
to be done by the kernel so yeah here
however we have a cannibal so it's of
course depends on machine but you can
see there is it's lagging and this this
is the simplest case so of course you
don't have two hundred sliders usually
but basically it's to show you how it
will scale if you do things wrong I mean
you should try to keep those small state
variables inside dynamic modules if you
have big data on the other hand it's not
good to keep them in the front end
because it's heavy
the more that dynamos will tries to
write things down to the notebook which
takes time too so you don't want to this
again not the main point briefly
mentioning okay what people don't know
what is very so is that animator is
implemented in the front end so if you
display an animator which is out running
it doesn't need to communicate to the
kernel and if this state variable is
connected to something that is also kind
of front-end related you may create
complete three front and side animations
actions whatever so here this part of
the question is and recently this is the
the progress indicator like customer
of course this the the bitmap is from
war from resources also but it it is run
completely front and side so you can
jump the loop or whatever do you don't
see the cell but it it is basically
ranked yeah so I did and nothing is
interrupted I assumed you should know
that if you have dynamic evaluations
they by default so around by preemptive
preemptive link so yeah while it
something kind of is running it can
still being kind of done because a print
I think can interfere without blocking
completely so yeah yeah things are
possible but this is nice because it
works completely front inside I will of
course not expect you to grasp this
advanced now it is for further like
appreciation you also may have noticed
that there are things mentioned with
content related context there are a few
private front-end context I wish it was
more documented it isn't but there are
things there are tricks that you can use
to program things that types it to
structures that are around complete
front and side so here we we use this
reference to the bitmap which won't be
written into the notebook which saves
you space in this notebook if you have
many images because you use them in in
your interface you don't necessarily
want to have them burned there you may
want to reference them the more if they
duplicate in many places in any controls
so this is the way what I also want to
stress here is that this is based all on
experience so I cannot recommend like
good tutorial on this but for example
here I could have made I measure from 2
to 2 P or from 0 to 2 P right so that I
can rotate around T I don't do
multiplication here but
but then if you know you would have
known that mmm
animator would need to risk IO because
by default it works from 0 to 1 that can
be done from front and side otherwise it
needs to go to the kind of tree scale
and this is the way to do this you don't
utter ranges to the animator you will
need but this however is a
multiplication that front end can do
itself this multiplication doesn't need
to go to the kernel so not every one is
straight words you cannot always ask the
fronton to do stuff but quite often it
can which is very nice all those things
are kind of enhancements for the
interface you may want to create so I
don't find it like very general
solutions but nevertheless I would like
to mention this ok so this is the
tutorial I mentioned where front end
side programming is mentioned there are
two lines on one section like this and
here is I think very useful example so
it's one of the style sheet which shows
you that your background color different
it's red or green whether you have below
11.1 version or not and while it's
important you could have put their
dynamic both we already know you can
have a dynamic front and 388 options so
you could you could have put their
dynamic but what I find very important
here is that this type of code won't
trigger dynamic warning insidious for
example and people are terrified because
we often give Sidious to lawyers they
don't know what's happening they think
we've broken something because they
there is this pop-up or toolbar at the
put the top that you need to enable
dynamic updating they don't know what's
going on and this doesn't sugar this so
because front-end of arrogance are
limited and if we put his dynamic we can
do many things it will go to the kernel
and so on and now we don't so that's
more about important improvement
okay so one is no front end limits also
and have the typesetting quotes again
why is this worse than this because
front end doesn't know how to display a
list let's say so from the nose without
the kernel how to display a number if it
is a number or a string for example but
this list needs to go to the kernel and
beat typeset so it's like a list of
small features issues that you need to
be aware of but then it is quite useful
you can enhance your interface okay so
it's the problem I won't show it here
because I think it's fixed in 11.3 but
basically there is a current value of
window size and if you move window
around without changing the window size
it this dynamic will be triggered yeah
was so you want to fix it before fixes
this because you have stuff to do so
this is an application of how to fix it
I should mention that this every private
may look like discouraging but you don't
need sometimes to use them those
contexts because content can pass it
like a set twenty knows if switch and so
on so you can just write it and it
should pass it correctly but somehow I
have a feeling that the useful name and
just to be clear about what's going on
and this is pretty dense a piece of code
how it helps us so basically we know
that the discarded by window size will
be triggered when the window size the
window is moved only so we set the CBS
CW as parallel to this size but if we
move it doesn't change so the dynamic we
really care about which is here won't be
triggered because c WS doesn't really
change and all this is done from the
inside because all those feed structures
types it has
a front-end structures and that's what
another stance again that was not the
main point so we are going to the main
point now that that was like a teaser
okay this is the big stuff basically we
want to write the big packets and we
find it hard to structure the code
correctly or in a way that's
maintainable and so on
so what state management I think do you
see how we have variable start here and
controlled here that is state management
so you have storage and control and you
pass things around here you pass things
around by typing them explicitly which
is fine for manipulates for simple
applications but as soon as you go
further you need sanicball so the basic
like item medium is to pass it by
reference with dynamic whatever you need
to hold the evaluation and pass it to
the controller yeah so this is what you
do and it I mean it doesn't do anything
but basically it works so but there
comes a problem now because that's also
a basic stuff and now dynamic system is
very special because you refresh
dynamics based on notation of symbols
front end or whatever whatever symbols
so if there is a mutation or change of
the value of the symbol it will trigger
dynamic objects which are linked to this
symbol now if you have an association
and let's say controller for each key if
you change one key everything linked to
this Association will be kind of
considered triggered there is no
separation of keys there is no
separation on our parts so what okay I
think I have an example yeah
yeah so this is the common container
program so yeah this is the list you
would like to control it to control only
the number there but you can see
everything is updated because you change
only part I mean okay that's how it
works so how do you do this
you pass this you create separate
symbols for each keys for example so you
have key one key to whatever can be
arbitrary but now you you are in a state
where there are 40 let's say it happened
to me that they were even more variables
and you need to pass them like we did
here all right so we need to write your
modules which accepts all those so good
luck with not making mistakes good luck
with very patient patience to do this
because I don't and if you know from the
wink what do you want it's easy but I
often people who don't so we totally
with them they say okay now let's change
this so they want to show let's yeah
here so this so this is an interface
let's say in our course and then now
it's almost down and that it's almost
done and they say that in this this
place they need a control that controls
something figure if you structure the
record in Medora
way now you need to create a new
variable that will pass from the green
dynamic module here and then here and
meanwhile it will be passing through
models that don't care like those red
ones or pink ones they don't care about
this variable but they need to pass them
down and still there is a problem of the
length that you need to did I make a
mistake with the order or not yeah I'm
just terrible I yeah that was the
motivation to do something about this so
the first thing is to understand dynamic
module yeah so we did the main loop
recap very briefly so
this is how much time equal input looks
and now yeah that's okay first we have
parsing stage so every symbol has a
context I you know simple context
because it doesn't matter so basically
we have X which was found in drama
context we'll have Y which was found in
its context we saw why it's important
but basically this is the parsing stage
this before evaluation so it was said to
the kernel first the box structure was
sent and passed to this then it's going
to be evaluated here nothing fancy
happens because dynamic holds it and
then module evaluation leads only to
this but already we see that there is a
dynamic module values option added
nothing fancy happened yet now we have a
typesetting stage so it's converted to
boxes like everything later
and we can see oh it's something to
change there is dollar dollar here mmhmm
and dynamic box of course it looks
slightly different but we see that
something changed in the structure we go
further there is an installation like I
don't know how to call it because I do
not know how it's called internally but
basically after typesetting and
displaying there is also installation of
course of dynamic module but we can also
see that this global was changed cell
context so I infer the current context
is replaced manually so that we can kind
of easily for example switch the context
of the knob you can easily works stuff
like this we just need to understand
what's going on because now we can abuse
it ok this was just a brief description
of how dynamic module works
Lu presented something more
user-friendly I believe and but not full
so I prepared something for here full
from what I can infer from experiment so
it's a bonus we won't go there because
it's not important but feel free to do
this okay so let's go it can create GUI
that doesn't have a problem of passing
variables around you need to create them
but you can do even do this
manually like or automatically I have a
deeply nested Association for
specification of this assessment I
mentioned earlier and I generate dynamic
holders automatically so that each key
is a separate dynamic what is variable
but then you have a problem how do you
access this well you don't need to pass
them so you need to access them in
controllers we will see how it can be
done
so this GUI don't be afraid it's only so
complicated because it has this
integration so we want to show a
progress indicator at the beginning and
then my panel but we can already see
that my panel doesn't need to be to have
any store X for example passed around
this store only context it's not special
I just put it there because you need to
be of control of the context however you
want this is one way you can use full
names but there are other ways it
doesn't matter now
ok so let's define my panel it's also a
nested why not I mean it's complex
application so you have my control my
plot in body button and by a button
we'll see why invite and my controller
yeah finally
ok so now we can abuse how typesetting
can't and copying works you need to have
big off control of the context I guess
head so you need to use the same context
then the name of the variable followed
by dollars but you can only use this
trick in things that will typeset
symbols so dynamic type set that
contains dynamic box which contains this
as a symbol not as a string for example
so if you have dynamic just store then
it will be a string doesn't matter we
don't use it but here it will be because
we want praten to Paris it further each
time dynamic module are initializes it
creates front and variable that is
shared between front and cannon and
stuff so at the end at the end this is
if you evaluate this basic stuff without
you see this is what is really there
there are at 34 we don't need we don't
know this diner
module number up front and it's changes
always so we wanted to do this so we
kind of me I didn't want to write user
interface inbox language so this is like
a hybrid I allow fronton to do what it's
supposed to do so I do this like here we
also have dynamic which wraps this
basically we need this in controls right
so they will be used correctly if this
right now you want to for example change
X from the procedures you can to get
from a button which convolve which
involves ethical questions in the kernel
this won't work if you defined it like
this because this invalid reset function
it won't be passed by the front end it's
it's don't for the catalog and front and
only sends this so to have by the way to
send stuff to the kernel we we need to
make it visible to the front end
basically so yeah this is the values
button it's the same but we only pass to
those functions what we need and before
it is sent to the kernel this is already
passed and it is already a correct
variable so let's try to run it yeah so
I mean maybe it's not very like
outstanding but we don't pass any
variable anywhere and it can be
arbitrary long list of variables that we
would need to and yeah yeah I'm that's
not what I want to do you see okay so
this is just just not related cross
indicator and now everything works in
Ventura set doesn't work because it's
not partly while it rest it works I mean
I love it I use it on daily basis now
the only problem of course is if you
have nested if you need to give
meaningful names for variables because
if you have nested structure of dynamic
modules and then names interfere yeah
but you should give meaningful names to
the variables anyway so that's good
habit to have which may also means that
it's not perfectly suited to create
controls for use for others so like
defining a slider for some
it's perfect for creating widgets or
applications which are you have full
control on or your team because you know
what's going on but it's worth it's
worth it
yep so you can see this is how how the
button with this looks like and yeah
this is a symbol which before evaluation
is sent to the neglect the kind of mm
correctly now yeah so I would like to
cry stop sorry
yeah I I'm sorry I needed to I needed to
finish
no questions probably can be asked
outside
I will leave first this notebook I'm
happy to answer questions because the
main point is to gather attention the
main point is this is like one piece of
the puzzle we need to have the best ways
to handle user Enterprise generation for
complex cases because this is what I
struggle a lot and I would like feedback
discussion yeah
[Applause]